ici c'est chez nous c'est un séjour au
motel qui n'a rien de touristique pour
jacqueline smet la raison qu'on attend
on met dans une chambre de motel c'est
justement les loyers avaient augmenté
épouvantablement une hausse de 350
dollars par mois loin des moyens de
jacqueline et son compagnon soit on
abandonne un choc qu'ont qu'on fait du
pousseur pour aller travailler ou
l'autre boom quelqu'un pour un drive où
il ya des coutures qu'était bougies
d'être fait dans ce département nigadoo
ils ont plutôt choisi de partir la
chambre de motel était alors la seule
option abordable sur le marché c'est pas
normal pour personne est obligée de
réduire puis pour incapable de vifs
pleinement dans l emportement porte
claque ou de vie est trop chère
c'est pour éviter que ce genre
d'histoire se répète que le gouvernement
de blaine higgs changent d'approché de
suzuka
pipi au lit
limite l'augmentation des loyers à 3,8
pour cent pendant un an la mesure sera
ensuite réévaluée l'opposition
officielle et les représentants des
locataires restent sur leur faim on
regarde d'autres provinces au canada qui
ont des contrôles qui sont ces trois
fois meilleur que le nôtre d'aidé de 1,5
pour cent de province est-ce que ça va
loin en suggérant sport pourquoi le
gouvernement n'a pas décidé de prendre
une mesure prise par maintenant
maintenant c'est pas une mesure radicale
le gouvernement réduira aussi de 50 %
sur trois ans les impôts fonciers
provinciaux pour les propriétaires
d'immeubles de logements mais plusieurs
doutent que les locataires en profitent
réellement l'idée derrière tout ça c'est
d'essayer d'inciter à la construction
résidentielle mais on faire face à des
pénuries majeur de personnel également
dans cette industrie là l'association
des propriétaires d'appartements se dit
aussi déçu souligne que la mesure ne
suffira pas à compenser la hausse des
prix des immeubles 35 millions 200 mille
dollars si le surplus prévu pour
l'exercice 2011 22 2023 si le budget du
nouveau brunswick est marqué par une
importante marge de manoeuvre bien des
ménages la province n'ont pas cette
chance il si mathieu papillon radio
canada